رائد النمس المتحدث باسم جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه ان طواقم
الهلال الاحمر تمكنت من اجلاء 7000 نازح
كانوا في مقر الهلال الاحمر في خان يونس
مشيرا في مقابله مع الجزيره الى اضطرار
خروج هؤلاء تحت تهديد السلاح
الاسرائيلي تمكنت طواقمنا يوم امس من
اجلاء وتوفير ممر
انساني لخروج نحو 7000 نازح كانوا متواجد
في مقر الجمعيه في خان يونس وذلك بعد حصار
المكان لاكثر من 15 يوما يعني هؤلاء
النازحين اضطروا للخروج تحت تهديد السلاح
الاسرائيلي والقصف المتواصل ومطالبه الجيش
الاسرائيلي لهم بالخروج من هذا المكان و
طبعا كانت رحله الخروج رحله صعبه جدا في
طريق وعره تمتد الى خسه كيلومترات
بالاضافه الى مرورهم عبر حاج واجز
اسرائيليه تعرضوا هناك للاستجواب والقمع
والتنكيل بهم ومعاملتهم معامله غير
انسانيه بالاضافه الى اعتقال عدد منهم
تبقى في خان يونس في مقر الجمعيه نحو 40
من كبار السن و 80 مريض ينطلقون العلاج لم
نستطع نستطع فنيا اخلاهم بسبب وجود خطر
على حياتهم اذا ما تم اخراجهم دون ترتيب
لوضعهم الصحي